in the last video we talked about
freelancing work in this video we're
gonna take a closer look at Ober as a
case study now you've probably heard of
uber by now
uber was recently valued at over fifty
billion dollars and they have operations
in over 50 countries their business
model is simple they connect people who
need a ride with drivers who are willing
to drive them using their own personal
vehicle now this sounds an awful lot
like a traditional cab company you're
right uber competes directly with
traditional cab companies but unlike cab
drivers uber drivers use their own car
and this means they're responsible for
all the costs associated with using
their vehicle maintenance and repair
costs for example the main service
provided by uber is this technology this
mobile application that connects people
and facilitates automatic payment too
many uber is symbolic of a technology
mediated on-demand or gig economy early
on uber and companies like it were seen
as offering a new and very exciting way
to work you could drive whenever and
wherever you wanted an uber claimed
early on that the median salary for a
driver working at least 40 hours a week
in New York City was $50,000 a year
since then people have challenged these
earning estimates and some people have
raised questions about some aspects of
ubers employment model the critical
issue is how these drivers are
classified whether their employees or
independent contractors the legal
distinction has important implications
for drivers experiences and protections
uber refers to its drivers as partners
but uber does not consider its drivers
employees and many feel that they have
virtually no input in the company
decisions including pricing and
passenger related policies for example
uber retains full control over the base
rates that drivers can charge uber
started off with higher fares but has
cut them on multiple occasions in order
to try to boost ridership in fact there
reports that uber X drivers uber X being
the most commonly used lowest cost
service make only a little bit more than
traditional cab drivers and that's
before factoring in all the cost that
cab drivers don't have also
Buber drivers can be fired automatically
by a computer if their passenger rating
below a 4.6 on a scale from one to five
drivers have no way of contesting
ratings that they perceive as being
unfair and uber doesn't tell its
passengers how their ratings might
affect drivers employment a passenger
might reasonably assume therefore that a
four star rating is pretty good but
actually four stars could nudge a driver
below a 4.6 and therefore out of a job
uber also collects analyzes and profits
from a wealth of driver data but is
guarded about which data are shared back
with drivers in some states drivers are
trying to organize and collectively
bargain so in California for example
drivers formed CA da which stands for
the California app based drivers
Association but these drivers faced a
difficult road ahead because US law does
not require uber to negotiate because
uber considers these drivers independent
contractors not employees in other words
they're not management's problem the
City of Seattle acted on its own
recently and passed the law that enabled
uber drivers to organize and negotiate
for better conditions next summer a
federal court in California will hear
arguments in a lawsuit that challenges
the way that uber classifies their
drivers as independent contractors
rather than employees so as it stands
the California app based drivers
Association is trying to bring publicity
to some of these issues but it doesn't
have very much leverage beyond that so
as Hillary Clinton points out this
on-demand or so-called gig economy is
creating exciting opportunities and
unleashing innovation but it's also
raising hard questions about workplace
protection and what a good job will look
like in the future beyond policy
solutions some entrepreneurs are
stepping forward with ideas for
improving on demand workers experiences
Sherpa share for example helps uber
drivers manage their earnings and job
related expenses and also connects them
with similar workers in their area so
the question that I would pose to you as
a class is what do you recommend that
Oberer drivers do to improve their
employment circumstances for one thing
do you think our current policies are
sufficient for on-demand workers if not
how might they be improved
how might workers cited technology
such as Sherpa share also improved the
experiences for these workers
you